let's see what this guy's to say this
guy seems like he's definitely I'm so
upset oh yeah it's a big club I'm
shocked you let ye laugh so early I have
sweet teeth yeah this I don't have
enough video it's not that we're gonna
be here all day
we should have been I dropped the ball
down I shot my shot and missed it's all
right man what's up guys so I got it a
big clip for you
so I'm just taking a break watching this
guy talk about how we just loves tugging
on his pecker and I'm gonna have a
little string cheese the debate club is
when you eat string cheese do you peel
it back like a young schoolgirl or do
you just bite into that [ __ ] like a
goddamn man debate it looks like you a
little me a little
I don't mix what do you think a younger
Brendon I do not look like that count
looks like my buddy veg ran from Eau
Claire you guys knew him you think I was
Brendan right now with the bedrock do
not pull up the drove probably clear we
already have enough pending litigation
what a great name though that's a real
friend dude you just made that up
from eclair okay he still even dessert
dude that's right well we didn't get the
donut God Brandon what happened to you
man something happening while I was out
of town years ago you would have known
that hey Johnny tiramisu is that your
buddy smuggle drugs for the cartel
across the border now it looks dude
eight string cheese like a goddamn
civilian of course I'll its string
cheese yeah its string its string for a
reason man and you didn't like a goddamn
educated man you think Elon Musk is
bitin anything like a [ __ ] caveman no
dude he's peeling it like an educated
soul
how do you guys do it in the far east
cat what are you guys doing uh well
we're really good luck with dairy right
Asian people are usually lactose
intolerant no we still eat cheese the
more you know gangster we don't really
care about that but we're really good
with following instructions so you
always gotta peel it
mmm well and Chappell see I didn't have
string cheese until I was adopted into
the white family right oh it's a white
snack yeah that's why it's a whitest
name yeah I've never had my family do a
pickle maybe in a little thing you know
you see like a hot oh my god yes yeah I
prefer black treats yeah you do like
treat oh yeah what are black treats it
would be like oh you said the hot dog
nugget a little comfortable you got that
a nighttime Tommy Bahama shirt oh my bad
yeah chef L if you're here you like
don't worry you're white ain't no FUBU
makes [ __ ] exotic sugar for Uruguay
by you're a no-call kunai makes [ __ ]
outerwear ocean edition debate club Pele
string cheese or bited Pele at 70
degrees of course dude what time the
finals when you bite it I noticed that
it's kind of shaped like it's they make
it so you're supposed to peel yeah yes
the way it's kind of like it's like kind
of tapered at the top you know the
layers yeah that thing's ready to be
peeled and instead of just to bypass all
of that and just bite into it with some
terrorist [ __ ] dude that's is this movie
very Isis man it's really it's just
bizarre fella what's that guy's name fed
drum it's almost upsetting do yeah yeah
bedroom dude you can buy in a chatter
like that yeah Merilee had the cheese
off Oh
that was a good one lassic who lost that
one you know is it yeah and then I lost
unsweet that's unbelievable
unreal unreal unreal I'm so
disappointment I thought you're gonna
win that was an upset I thought it was a
layup I'd be the first see ya there's
not a lot of blueberry you could've went
with cherry mmm yeah I said coconut
cream dude that's so good a banana
banana kinder banana custard banana
rhubarb pie just your cobbler flavorless
gelatin flavorless you can get some
jello I guess it's kind of a cheap snack
gone I mean it's good I shouldn't you
need your sugar free jello that's what
bodybuilders eat for sweet tooth
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]